ما هي الاجراءات التي يمكن الان ان تكون
جاريه الى حين دخوله عبر هذه الابواب
والمضي قدما الى المحكمه
طبعا بعد وصوله واخذ معلوماته
وبصماته وتلك الصوره المشهوره التي تسمى
بماج شات من كافه الجوانب وفق ما ورد من
معلومات او لن تؤخذ صورته بهذا الشكل بعد
ذلك
يؤخذ الى غرفه انتظار عاده يؤخذ المتهمون
الى زنزانه ولكن مع ترامب سيؤخذ الى غرفه
انتظار من بعدها سيتم نقله او تحريكه الى
تلك القاعه التي تتحدثين عنها وهي قاعه
المحكمه هذا عمليه الانتقال هذه تسمى
باللغه الانجليزيه لها مصطلح مشهور وهي
حين يتم او تقوم وسائل الاعلام بتصوير
المتهم لدى انتقاله من مكتب الادعاء العام
الى القاضي ليواجه التهم وعاده يكون مكبل
بالاصفاد ولكن ايضا وفق ما قاله محامي
ترامب واذ ما تم لن يكبل نظرا الى انه
سيتم نقله تحت حمايه شرطه الخدمه السريه
طبعا هناك دوما الكثير من المفاجات وغير
المتوقع بما ان لا شيء مؤكد رسميا من قبل
السلطات هنا بعد ذلك يمثل امام القاضي
القاضي سمح فقط بخمس مصورين فوتوغرافيين
لاخذ صور بدايه الجلسه من ثم يخرجون هناك
سيكون تواجد صحفي داخل القاعه ولكن يمنع
التصوير او التسجيل يمنع استخدام الهواتف
او
الحواسيب لذا على الارجح حين يتم تلاوه
التهم على ترامب رسميا من قبل القاضي لن
يكون ذلك الجزء مصورا
يعني بشكل على مصور على شكل بث حي لكي
نتابعه او نراه او نعلم فعليا ما حدث